Alejandro
Jackwerth doch trotz aller Welt alle und
die normal Haren
der Mann hatte geklagt
Hauptzweck also im Aufgebot führen
Dr
okay Cloud
wir sehen hierin die lan-verbindung
wir haben keine Kosten gestreut
bitte Rezepte einfach taugten
Corner
RW haben diesen Weg man nachgestellten
könnt euch darin setzen
wie ist die Lage
um ich bin links träge
was trägst du nimmst
ja was wohl
okay also grundsätzlich MSC Lage mehr
links orientiert
er ist aber wie ruhig allgemein bei
wollte dies so
und auch um alle beschnitten
das ist Grundvoraussetzung
okay ja um
Bild
das gilt für uns alle auch politisch
defintiv politisch auch beschnitten ja
Gevelsberg aber
die Randalierer seien weniger politisch
als mehr im Unterhaltungsbereich
richtig das ist genau richtig
ja
ist jemand hat uns gleich im Comedy auf
YouTube
um an finden und zur Politik ihn
da und hört heute hier genau und ja
im heute halt mehr aber wie ist die Lage
versetzt überlingen wer das ist
spannend aber Fr
mit
die Idee zu recht so
das Super
alles cool
ziemlich ideales Gefährt und wir
bleiben hier» Bieber macht mir
Gudrun lange Kosten aber und Mädchen
dann
er muss ich einfach rausschmeißen
um über das Projekt dann gekommen da
sich abseits von Morgen aus
Hilpoltstein wie lange braucht man einen
nach Köln
durch gute vier Stunden geflogen
Rolf Löhmann losgefahren
wie zuletzt lebte
Nein fühlt euch da man manchmal ein
bisschen am Arsch der Welt
so
was mir jetzt schon persönlichen Köln
aufgefallen sie habt ihr keine
Nein haben wir nicht das ist klar was
ist ihr dann wir wissen auch gar nicht
wie die aussehen her
weil er schon überlegt ob wir schon
irgendwie vielleicht zu lang
mit Kannibalismus Richtung Mini ihr
müsst euch wahrscheinlich um ein Depot
bei wir haben auch ihre ehe die ein oder
andere die Tür ist noch offen oder
diesen Orten gut wie sonst soll die
Arzneien werden auch eine durchaus so
Ralf Barkey um
aber wie sagte lange dem Film angefangen
gekommen waren im am Arsch der Welt auf
die Idee wie wirst du Mont kennt man
dann so was wie Videos Videokameras um
den Ball wieder zurück für Spiegel
also das ist das ist schon richtig dazu
dass Prozent sagst es um
das hängt definitiv zusammen wir werden
in der Großstadt nicht draufgekommen
Videos zu machen
also ist Ware aus Langeweile
Amir angefangen
um man konnte nicht viel tun ausser
über Wacker Rennen und
es gelten
und Prozente Jahr dann hatte ich eine
Kamera geschenkt bekommen und wir haben
da wirklich einfach mal gesagt okay
lassen Video machen
und das kam so gut an bei unseren
Freunden wir müssen paar Freunde
geschickt Jungs weitergeschickt also in
dieser Internet lief perfekt virale hat
sich das verbreitet
und um das kam so gut an dass wir gesagt
haben
machmal auch Heinz Sundt das kann wieder
an und so ging es weiter und wir wollten
uns immer steigern und so ist heute die
eigentlich entstanden
eben weil wir im Arsch der Welt wohnen
haben die diese Videos gemacht
Knatsch
Natasha ja
das heißt
aber wie hatte er hat sie sich direkt
von Anfang an so gut verbreitet weil es
gibt ja andere Leute auch Unternehmen
die den Stettener richtig Power einer
mit ihrem Video sich wieder reif
verbreiten
hat das beugt Dreck von Anfang an
funktioniert Nein also Anfang was er
liest Freunde Aktes 1000 User Source
Jana Lehmann auf anderen Portalen of Pop
ebenso wie das hochzuladen zu verbreiten
und so kam ihm bis hin zu Tumoren und
irgendwann Camus dann ging es dann von
selber wie muss man nichts vormachen es
hat sich verbreitert natürlich am
Anfang hat das langsam angefangen nackt
und Punk Post Wohlen erkannt habt ihr
das funktioniert da
a da gucken die Leute mehr der im
betreuen Adresse das hatte
Herr Heine die Heizung müsse man nicht
viel machen et voilà eingegebenen kamen
wie an Land Bahn
das heißt im Markt da direkt
mit Brauner immer bei den Proben dabei
Generation Web erträgt also wir waren
ja dann von 2009 enden bis jetzt zu 90
17 das geht dann durch zwei Leben die
letzten sechs Monate haben mit 1 8 nach
zig tausend Abonnenten mehr bekommen
was ist das für euch ist das ein
Problem
oder
ist dass man Beruf
oder ist es schon Beruf
ganz schwer zu sagen also es ist
definitiv keine Miene kein reines Hobby
aber es wird immer ein Problem bleiben
weil wenn es kein Hobby mehr es bei
Comedy tanken wird das auch nicht lustig
und Prozent
m das ist aber schon fast mit dem was
wir im
Moment machen also ich mein jetzt sind
wir in Köln
Prozent an der verschiedenen Projekte
wir kommen wirklich für um die nächste
WM Hollywood okay das ist jetzt nicht
Arbeit oder so
es ist schon fast so miesen fulltime-job
geworden
und deswegen
um gut das Geld stimmt halt noch nicht
deswegen würde ich auch jetzt nicht
unbedingt Beruf sagen
aber ist es so ein Zwischending zwischen
Hobby und Beruf und ich will würden
Scanner zum
ausweiten wobei es gab immer schon mal
Ansätze ich hab gelesen Prozent
Premiere war damals noch
hatte sich an euch gewendet um Trainer
zu machen es ist immer wieder was
gekommen aber noch berichtigt draus
geworden
die Pflicht auch mal anfangen sehr
langen Atem um aus YouTube woanders hin
zu kommen oder ist das sie solle im
Sommer Bands die man nur sehr schwer
beschreiben kann das ist euer gefühlt
also
das stimmt schon es ist schwierig aus
dem Internet um
vor allem in Deutschland glaube ich noch
schwierig aus dem Internet ins in die
anderen Medien zu kommen aber ist dann
TV folgt das richtige
or Erkrath
ganz gut Fragen stellen
dass das passiert
das Fragen wir uns auch er
also
kommt drauf an was die uns vorschlagen
wenn jüngsten SketchUp ihm auf
ProSieben
Münzen SketchUp Lied auf ProSieben
aber was muss eine Bedingung sein damit
wir das machen würden Verwendung Sache
müssen machen was wir wollen
das muss die Bedingung sein
nicht unbedingt wenn die jetzt sagen er
also wir lassen uns schon auch ein
bisschen
einschränken aber jetzt nicht komplett
wenn ich sagen macht uns was lustiges
zuvor Highlight oder per IPO teuer oder
und Neffen Parodie gerne aber halt nicht
genau erhielt heuer
m Drehbuch und genau das müsst ihr zu
für uns machen
und nicht anders
und auf fünf Jahre und jedes nichts
anderes wer in der Zeit machen das
wollen wir nicht
zum Beispiel poliertes wer richtig auch
unser Richtung so Schedl noch Live auf
der Bühne ebenso
Lights gesperrt Formen
das wär ganz cool für uns das können
wir so vorstellen Wünsche Pulli
ich kann zu wem wobei hier machte Moment
was anders ist er alles andere als
leicht ist es ja wirklich durch
geschrieben was euch habt von vielmehr
auch unterscheidet
Prozent das ist er nach Drehbuch
gemacht Unfall am Drehbuch
wo ich ihn Fragen möchte wo habt ihr
das gelernt
ist das aus dem Deutschunterricht
um
wer nie spontan
m die Ideen kommen unterschiedlich
befindet kommen sie zum Beispiel in
Physik lernen
beim 2 0 schnell
Bernie als sie ich stieg die meiste der
vom schlafen gehen bin ich
kurz vom einlegten den Springer war auch
von Schalke Ideen auf
und wie aber muss
früher as unterschiedlich Misses
familiär so bezahlt lagen
mal einige Ideen und dann Live keiner so
ist es unterschiedlich bei uns
und
die ganzen Ideen aufzuschreiben
Kirsten Olympia Buch wichtig immer
wollte
professionelle Zielen
Besitz von Klem Erde
die Hüter
nur die zwei Bühnen
ein vor zwei Jahren Sommer
den Piloten gedreht haben da haben die
das hat er gelernt wie man habe bisher
über die
und auch gelernt Netz mittlerweile
versuchen wir das dann halt 60
professionelles zu machen
was alles was wir gelernt haben haben
wir und selbst beigebracht oder von
anderen abgekocht
im Prozess ist nicht so «dass wir
irgendwo mal
Lauf der Schule waren für sowas Kalsow
Nasemann Knie also ich bin ich
Hauptschule oder sowas weißen
kann schon Deutsch reden um zu löschen
aber Prozent
ja da kommt das her
und
es ist halb John so unser Uru [ __ ]
das ist einfach
ganz viel Dramatik inne vollkommen
bescheuerte
Situation einzubringen bestes Beispiel
ist unser
da sind der Besen Sketchen
genau und der ist ja auch wirklich bei
e-bay unseren Heimen Fans ist er schon
so noch in einem der Sketch der am
besten ankommt
der hat zwar noch nicht so viele Klicks
gehabt weil hat ihm kein Edward und
keine Behlert Remark
aber das ist auch so was wo wie vor
dahinter stehen bislang sowas ist kein
Tag an dem ich selbst etwas schlapp
machen
wir auch nicht im wie diese
Bilder mit nackten Brüsten und dann
bläst einem Besen Einener so wir haben
einfach das Center Besen die normalen
Bild und da wollte ich auch gar nicht so
Naomi auf Macs enthaltenen das war
einfach und sass der CES
die mir einfach so zeigen wollten ohne
große Titten und Zwanzigers aber wie
kommt er damit gerechnet dass er manche
Gratwanderung er hat also schon ein paar
Mails angesprochen wenn ich auf YouTube
Erfolg haben will dann brauche ich die
richtigen
mit Text das heißt die Suchwörter die
auch gesucht werden
am besten auch im Titel ich brauchen
Samwer was geguckt wird also ich bin ja
immer in diesem wieder Streit
weil es gibt der Konkurrenten
die machen sagt Prozent extensiv Prozent
er ist mir in dieser Situation wie die
Liste sei der Wert sie gespalten mache
ich mache es nicht oder welchen Weg
gewählt Dr
hier Klagen wenn man sieht dass durch
sowas eben auch die Tics hochgehen
muss man sich irgendwie anpassen und wie
schleifte man hinterher wenn man ihn
nicht diesen Strom mit geben
wenn welche Typen machen
müssen natürlich auch Titel machen
womit er würzte Klicks bekommen
Templeton Beute gemacht hätten mehr hat
aber wir müssen leider nach tief ins
aus schade sei nicht nur so geht um
viele Klicks zu bekommen
ja aber dazu wollte ich auch mal sage
also wir halten das eingrenzen weil es
gibt wirklich Dinge so Tricks auf
YouTube die einfach zu weit gehen
und um die probieren wir dann auch um
zu unterlassen
um was wir uns halt dann überlegt haben
wir haben uns zusammengesetzt und Jahr
passt mal auf hier gibt's jetzt Leute
auf YouTube die ging hier richtig viel
schreiben und die tricksen darum ohne
Ende
und die kriegen viel mehr Abonnenten und
letztendlich fällt es niemanden mehr
auf dass die tricksen weil sie dann in
Sophie Bekanntheit haben dass das dann
auch Regale Smole herkommt
und da haben wir uns überlegt wie wir
das machen und hier
wie der Thalys schon gesagt hat ihm
dieses Zwischending
und was ist eigentlich das wichtigste
ist ist das bei uns trotzdem die
Qualität der Videos Stimmen sollen
das ist eigentlich unser Grundsatz also
man kann ja letztendlich schauen die
Leute ja dann das Video nur an aufgrund
des Vorschaubild und des Titels und da
kann man dann auch ein Video machen
Prozent votiert sie einfach
tanzt als Frau verkleiden in der
Innenstadt okay dass er schon wieder
lustig
und 4 laut Schröder schwelgt
wie aber halt eben noch schlechter und
das wird dann genauso aufgeklebt und das
wollen wir definitiv nicht machen
also unsere Videos sollen qualitativ
hochwertig bleiben
und noch besser werden und es werden
noch besser Videos kommen so wie das
Radio letzten Freitag das war zum
Beispiel richtig geil
oder doch mehr ja das war auf der ganzen
Welt Bergwerke bieten ihre Werke
um aber normal für alle in diversen gab
was kann man den tricksen bei YouTube
sind dass die Texte mit denen man sich
Sammer schummeln die damit nähern
wie kann man
also was sie was macht ihr nicht
was wir nicht machen ist zum Beispiel
dass wir am Ende von dem Video einen
sagen hier geht's zu Teil zwei und dann
kommt man wieder auf dasselbe Video
um zum 1
jetzt zum Beispiel was wir auch nicht
machen es
was auch bestimmt schon vorgekommen ist
im normalen YouTube dass man
was tun ab
Dinge verlost 5 Prozent
die sich im Mittelfeld
die man ja dass man ihn sagt Manfred
Brust sind etwas und
Prozent ja lästern das Video man gesagt
hat dass Manz verlost hat und hat es
dann doch nicht verlost Polch auch nur
mal so darf ich immer ganz akut wir
haben wir verlosen jetzt übrigens nennt
Lamborghini
Nila Ann wollte die Farbe um mit
Autogrammen
und zwar nur wenn ihr Argument von White
IT Sold und Clixoom
und er ist
man muss kreativ Center me in the
Command schreiben könnt ihr einen Pool
Ambiente gewinnen noch Metier
ihr könnt auch zehn Tennis machen
dann um der neue Gewinnchancen höher
Scherzinger und alles zu verändern er
alles allein über Eltern er war gerade
überhaupt alle wegen uns verloren das
auch e on hat Anfang an hätte unser
Postfach ab die auch immer
der Wagen in dem Pettigrew hinterlässt
Brief
ertappt
so funktioniert das
jetzt noch mal genau woher kommt der
Krise weit gediehen
so dass bei einem nächtlichen Situation
jeweils eine Stelle beworben habe Ayat
Menschen gebildet und erkannte auf den
Namen Bad Vilbel
beschnitten Duisburg RPO das besondere
Art Scharnier doch
okay weil aber jetzt immer mieser Name
entstanden Weizen ist klar aber wie kam
das die Briten dran
also ist los nicht immer muss der Halter
vorher
der TuS beim Kika Live Writer Wort
Prozent zurück -yr die Hälfte der
Sendezeit lang erklärt bevor
und die arbeiten zur Reifung die
Geschichte ist wirklich nicht
interessant also ich sags euch Prozent
ein von Saks die jetzt einfach mal kurz
zusammengefasst also Ciolos tief steht
für YouTube
das Dozententeam
tih tih er hat sich dann mehr oder
weniger durch Scherben Spielerei
ausweicht Scientific Inc
und weil Tiere die Standards für
YouTube damit soll die Sonne Abschnitt
der Sache ganz am Anfang gemacht haben
und das war es schon
wenn mir interessante Storey hast Nein
es aber endlich dieses mal gesagt
erscheinen endlich ist mal gesagt Frau
doch bitte nicht mehr Fragen können sie
aber das wird nicht schön sie sind bei
uns auch nur eine Frage wird immer
gestellt Little Bit ly er kann gut gehen
um aber im normalen Teamarbeit die wir
über das ist euer Problem er hat keine
Freundin
ohne Gewähr doch wer am Meer um ein
Topmodel
ein zukünftige ist und bei uns dabei
fühlt Schwester die hilft uns halt
hinter der Kamera
aber
herum dass nach sich ziehen und ich bin
eine sexy Brände also ein bisschen
weiblichen
Pocher mehr aufgeholt haben
hier seien du bist ja auch schon in
weibliche Rollen geschlüpft indische
findet
ja ich habe nicht so einfach auch mal
probieren müssen
Tasci hat gesehen dass Sinti sie das so
viel Spaß macht
es war die das war dieser eine Moment wo
ich zurückkam und wir wollten ein ich
muss gelten gehen
dann stand aber dahin
da im roten Kleid und hat sich so da es
lediglich BP Bekele der Realität
vermissen unser Sketche ich will eine
Frau werden und Bousdoukos ist
stehen das war ihnen Kainz geht das weit
ist fürchterlich hätten
also wer kann schon verstanden Shame
spielte genau
um
BP steht bei der gerne Frauen aber ist
euch das erlaubt Hey ich stopfe ich war
ein Albert ist in Ungarn fast so blöd
sind wir auch nicht dass es nicht auch
für das uns das wurde
Manfred Giese so habe ich das nicht
gesagt dass sie beide gerne Frauen
spielen sondern
lasst das mal probieren wollte sie Orgel
einmal aber Gerber Japan soll als mal
probiert die Simone Löffler machen ist
es euch nicht unangenehm meint war
also wer kommt da sicher der ein oder
andere kommen da ich habe sich ein neuer
Kommentar gelesen aber Oliver Mack jeder
hat Mensch der auf YouTube ist wird als
schwul bezeichnet
das kann sportlich fällt Jahrhundert
der Markt Dritter würde
irgendwann nachgeben wenn der größte
Markt für das Schulfach Religion Weimar
bei dem Unwetter noch erklären
um
in einer so
im Anzug sitzt entschlossen Deiche immer
die Frau Spiel das ist auch unser
Markenzeichen ist
um
aber ich bin keine Tote also keine Angst
meine Mutter doch die Perücke Oman
entdeckt und meinte so
Prozent und Tier ist also Tieschen ich
habe zwar eine Frage endlich ändern
lachen ich nicht sagt es denn
sie betont
ich Liebe es los
dabei trete ich bin auch keine Tote
Schulter Mai an ich bin ein machen
ja
beraten muss halt Benehmen muss zu
spielen ist ja nicht ganz lustig und ist
letztlich doch schon bekannt dass heute
die in das ich immer die Frauen Spiel
ich bekomm auf die Frage aber
Sommer Grüne andere Rolle zu schlüpfen
oder mir gefällt's und es ist total um
die Themen Krieg er hebt die kleinsten
zwickt und zwackt
um
inwieweit hat er mein Leben verändert
also ich glaube voll und ganz privat
doch es ist Wahnsinn
Ersatz total verändert
um ich
Hagen Band denke manchmal nach
widersetzt werden das mit wollte die
mich gekommen wäre
und dass wer die fini- tief ganz anders
also ich wären andere Mensch auch weil
so viele Jahre lang Comedy zu machen die
schon irgendwie im Internet tauchten
bisschen lernen also sehr viel von ihr
mir auch preiszugeben die Leute wissen
ja dann schon so ein bisschen wer du
bist
und um ja das dass das verändert sich
auf jeden Fall das macht ich zu einem
anderen Menschen inwieweit
Prozent ich bin
dievini tief um offener anderen
gegenüber selbstbewusster
lustiger mag ich sogar zu bezweifeln
manchmal also das ist um
das ist schwer zu sagen vielleicht davor
auch schon sehr lustiger Mensch glaube
ich
aber ich bin nicht jeder mit auch mehr
so Kraus Altig Ansicht wird ab ob wir
das Meer zu zeigen was wären alten
geworden wenn das nicht passiert wäre
bwl-student
50 mehr vor Ort gibt mehr Nero dass
Steuerberater oder der gibt so viele
schöne Sachen
Anwalt
Feuerwehrmänner wie soll er Weg gewesen
wir nicht abgezeichnet
das ist umso dass das ganze schon
um mit Theater angefangen hat bei mir
und das Prozent weit die Tiere nicht
Meermann von das Hobby war
und Seeadler die große Leidenschaft und
das Schauspielen
und dass ich das jetzt ausdrücken
langen schon so ein bisschen dreht
einfach weil diese Comedy Sache halt so
gut gelaufen ist
und um das Theater läuft es nicht
schlecht aber an das Prozess natürlich
hat er ganz andere Reichweite so das ist
halt im kleinen Rahmen und das White IT
geht ja wirklich durch Deutschland
und was war zumal die anfangs Frage ich
was der Anlass gewesen wäre er habe ich
ja ich fast immer Server wurde
und genau prüfen werde ob der Verwalter
bei der Saubermann entwickelt der Verein
auch
anfangs waren wir ja auch
trotz es schon peinlich im Internet und
ich glaube nicht dass ich im jetzt
Denker werden könnte
und wenn nicht dann sagt Hallo ich bin
ein Mathies 80 hat sie doch schon
gesehen in der Rubrik Outfit schöne
Pedelec in Verden sie dargestellt
natürlich ein Titel von SAP Kunden
betreuen das würde uns der Spaß machen
ich glaub das will ich nicht Weg um wir
haben aber wer misst gestern soll auch
die Frage gestellt was wäre wenn mir
nicht gesagt hätten hält mitdrehen das
jetzt was wird aus uns geworden
wie schwer es Bohlen würde im Michel
Prozent die Wehr abschießen unerwähnt
Steuerberater los dass wir es tun
früher gute Frage bestellbar Schein
Lich Prozent zu
Euro die Stunde Naturwissenschaften
Beschützerin
im Labor
mit weißem Kittel mit zurückgedrückt
ich bin Brille
ich würd ich irgendwelche Sachen
vermischen
da ist er auch ganz cool finde ich danke
aber selbst wer normal ist wollen wir
alles nicht mehr Bolton zusammen
den weiblichen Wege gehen
es wäre natürlich ideal dass es klappt
oder
man weiß wie
als einen «Flop» wir sind doch alle
drei Realisten uns ist schon klar dass
Prozent ein der Weg den wir uns
ausgesucht haben oder in die Nähe zu
Rhein geholt stimmt auch da das ja
verdammt schwer ist und dass man jetzt
nicht einfach sagen kann ich bin
Comedien oder wir werden Comedien
aber wir wollen
einfach alles Prozent hat denke ich
während Prozent uns mögliche dafür
tun
& Cie der Plan ist jetzt auch so dass
wir das nächste Jahr jetzt nach dem Abi
kann man sich auch mal ein Jahr Auszeit
zu leisten
und danach immer noch studieren immer
noch BWL studieren
und um das wird's wirklich mal so das
nächste Jahr einfach schauen was da
geht und einfach mit Spaß komme nie
machen das am besten jeden Tag 24
Stunden lang Cloud dann müsst ihr euch
dabei viel Erfolg
vielen dank Prozent wir werden sicher
noch öfter sehen
als YouTube war und um ich freue mich
auf alles das was da passiert und das
Qualifying wird im Fernsehen
im Prozentbereich online-video ist
einfach alles noch in Bewegung und kann
noch alles passieren
das stimmt und wir freuen uns auf den
Verkauf
viel Erfolg Dankeschön gleichfalls